voilà des années qu'on n'a pas vu à la
télévision il a choisi tout le monde en
parle pour son retour médiatique tout le
monde va en parler voici anthony de loin
à
ballon
alors déconne
quand on est dans cette émission il ya
beaucoup de jolies filles et pas
beaucoup de beaux garçons je crois que
là ce soir c'est d'être servi d'abord il
ya anthony de l'an ensuite il ya jean
marc barr et après il ya hervé bourges
alors anthony delon c'est vrai que ça va
vous exprimer rarement comme ça à la
télévision vous on vous voit peu mais je
crois que j'avais envie finalement de
vous montrer tel que vous êtes vraiment
parce qu'à un moment vous en avez marre
des rumeurs des ragots défaut aux images
c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps que je
suis pas venu la télévision jeux j'avais
pris le parti de devenir uniquement pour
parler de films d'ailleurs je le fais
aussi un peu ce soir dans ce pays qu'on
qui sort bientôt aussi les membres
nommés
et puis voilà et puis je suis content
d'être là ce soir car devrait donc
bientôt nous verrons anthony delon dans
jeu de cons c'est un film de jean-michel
vermeer avec frédéric diefenthal on va
en parler mais d'abord on va parler de
votre vie je dirais pas que c'est un jeu
de combat mais il ya eu pas mal de
conneries quand même
moi ya tellement gmail qui mendient
thierry sois gentil arrête de chanter
que dès qu'il ya un sampler je ferme ma
gueule d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
d'e-mails quittons dit ker ys les gens
qui arrêtent oui
donc finalement c'est bien alors anthony
delon ses 36 ans vous êtes né à los
angeles vous êtes le fils d'alain delon
bien sûr et de nathalie delon nathalie
delon vit aux états unis depuis depuis
une vingtaine d'années paraît qu'elle
veut rentrer en france
alors je sais pas si les gens se
souviennent parce que les gens n'étant
pas connus nathalie delon c'était un
couple absolument extraordinaire votre
père et votre mère parce qu'il se
ressembler mais vraiment il avait
vraiment le même look sexy de la mue en
bourse ont appris
hier une ressemblance parfaite et il
s'habiller pareil vous avez des photos
de cette époque pensait qu'ils étaient
frères et se voit là
c'était pas le cas non c'était pas le
voit sur et déjà ce soir on va tordre le
cou à toutes les rumeurs à tous les
scandales nathalie delon alain delon
n'était pas frère et soeur voilà alors
vos parents divorcent qu'on faisait
quatre ans c'est une fêlure pour vous
parce qu'on dit toujours que les
divorces finalement il vaut mieux des
parents qui divorcent que des parents
qui s'engagent enfants demande jamais la
vie des enfants et souvent quand on
interviews des enfants qui ont envie qui
sauvent et les adultes on s'aperçoit que
ça a été très douloureux pour eux
c'était le cas pour vous non parce que
moi c'est arrivé très jeune ils ont
divorcé quand j'avais 4 ans donc en fait
je me souviens absolument pas d'avoir
vécu avec l'un et l'autre avant cette
période dont je je
c'est pas une des choses qui m'a le plus
marqué je veux dire lors de wiener ce
qui s'appelait loulou et un leloup vous
la voyez toujours le nez je la vois
toujours bien sûr vous avez quatre
enfants
et puis un parent qui est georges au
baume qui est un agent historique du
cinéma français qui étaient en fait
votre vrai père qua non mon vrai père
c'est alain delon et suit
biologie bien sûr georges boum c'était
c'est toujours mon parrain donc si vous
voulez
mon parrain était là c'est vrai mon père
a été là aussi ça a été différent mais
mon père travailler beaucoup mon parrain
aussi mais il n'était plus disponible il
avait 20 ans de plus en général plus on
vieillit plus on est disponible pour les
gens qui sont proches de nous et c'est
vrai que j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
avec lui et qui m'a appris beaucoup de
choses alors bon alain delon on connaît
les problèmes que vous avez eue avec lui
on va pas y passer la soirée simplement
lui il a déclaré je voulais les levées
dans la rigueur et la discipline
il m'a échappé il a refusé mon autorité
pour une vie plus facile vous vous êtes
d'accord avec ça non il veut la même
chose que moi il va même chose que tout
père si vous voulez c'est dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous fonder une
famille avec une femme vous avez un
enfant c'est l'osmose c'est le trinôme
parfait et est notre seul désir qui est
le mien aujourd'hui puisque moi aussi je
super c'est de réussir ma vie de famille
et d'essayer de rester unie plus
longtemps possible et de
et d'y arriver donc c'est vrai que la
rupture pour lui a été difficile pour
nous pour tout le monde et c'est vrai
qu'il avait probablement une idée bien
précise de ce qu'ils avaient envie de
faire et il n'a pas pu le faire pour moi
parce que parce que la vie en a décidé
autrement et que et que normalement
quand deux parents divorcent l'enfant va
avec sa mère ce qu'il a beaucoup choqué
votre père saisit été réformés service
militaire pour insuffisance mentale
et/ou psychologiques chez lui l'avait
fait la guerre quand même l'indochine
dans ses tâches auxquelles vous fassiez
réformer le service militaire écoutez je
sais pas on en a jamais parlé mais je me
suis fait réformer ouais aujourd'hui
vous avez envie de régler les problèmes
un peu avec votre père vous dites je ne
voudrais pas enterrer mon père sur des
points de suspension en theresa pas le
faire marrer beaucoup mais je vous dit
je ne voudrais pas porter cela jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours ça me ferait
vraiment trop mal ça vous embête rai 2
finalement votre père disparaissent
avant que vous soyez réconcilier mon
père et moi bien sûr qu on s'est
réconciliés quand je je dis ça je dis qu
en fait il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu un
trou de 15 ans et on s'est perdus de vue
mon père ne me connais pas je le connais
pas et c'est vrai que le travail
aujourd'hui c'est pas de ceux de se
revoir et de faire parler parce que ça
s'est fait parce que parce qu'on s'aime
mais c'est surtout de d'apprendre à se
connaître et de retrouver si vous voulez
cette union qui doit normalement exister
entre un père et un fils mais sans se
connaître ça prend du temps et puis et
puis lui l'économie des mois je suis
comme je suis un chacun
sait ça donc c'est ça c'est mal et
j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir qu'il est
avant de l'enterrer ci par le premier il
quel jour là parce que
tu as la date de l'enterrement de mon
père c'est incroyable la façon dont tu
parles oui mais tu sais pas ce que l'on
projette toujours et puis on vit un
accident peut vite arriver regarde par
andy par un peu nombreux sur la ficelle
puis avoir un accident votre vote à
thizy
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir un
accident vient alors non il ya eu des
histoires on se souvient tous 185 votre
père vous interdit d'utiliser la marque
à d pour vendre vos blouson en cuir vous
étiez en train de faire une bonne
affaire parce que vous étiez je ne
savais pas deuxième des ventes derrière
mac douglas
ça se passait bien j'ai pas en fait non
ça a été un peu déformés jeu la marque
ça plaît pas à des as après anthony
delon donc mon pea prix pas m'empêcher
de le faire c'est plutôt si vous voulez
les gens avec qui il a il a signé son
contrat de licence qui ont commencé à
lui dit on en attend d'autres filles
s'il fait ça etc etc vous étiez associé
avec un garçon qui était directeur de
boîte de nuit qui s'est fait tirer
dessus à l'époque qui s'appelait
tordjman ont été convoqués à la brigade
criminelle ce qui a fait aussi que ça
n'a pas aidé cette affaire de blues ont
rien à aider et non c'est sûr que quand
son associé se fait flinguer dans sa
voiture c'est pas
donc après on a eu des impayés et puis
on a déposé le bilan
alors vous avez été interpellé deux ans
avant avant cette affaire donc en 83
dans une bmw volée est dans la boîte à
gants il y avait le pistolet voler un
policier lors de l'évasion de bruno
sulak qui est l ennemi public numéro un
j'ai piqué la mauvaise bagnols ouais
alors votre père est venu vous chercher
à la prison et vous n'avez pas été sympa
cherchez la plaisance vous avez dit il
vient me chercher pour se faire de la
pub
ça lui a pas plu est fâché t'es pas
content non j'ai dit ça parce que
j'ai dit ça parce que j'ai vu dans la
photo qui était je pense en couverture
de deux matchs crew ailleurs un
photographe qui était son photographe
personnel à l'époque et qui était là
alors je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il
fout là donc si vous voulez j'en ai
déduit
ouais quand vous êtes arrivé dans la
prison de la cellule on vous a dit il y
avait un type la yougoslave il s'est
pendu il ya quelques jours ceux ci
pensent de lui il s'est pendu hier
hier il a cassé les vitres mais ça s'est
bien goupillé
tu sais en prison en france on n'a pas
beaucoup de place
des 15 1 qui dégage on met notre place
sérieux là vous êtes vie quand même la
seule un peu loin quand même non je me
suis dit mais pourquoi ils m'ont mis
dans cette cellule
et puis surtout que les fenêtres étaient
cassées il faisait un froid de canard je
me vois tout ça a commencé j'avais fait
une fugue en fait au départ parce que
vous annoncez à votre père cool est
photographe c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé la dissension entre vous et
exige est envoyé en maison de correction
en pologne où la vie c'est vrai que
j'ai arrêté l'école je voulais plus
aller à l'école jeu la première année de
donc de première le premier jour la
première heure je m'assois en classe et
le type commence à parler je suis là je
me dis [ __ ] j'en peux plus c'est fini
ouais faut que je me casse je dis
monsieur oui est ce que je peux et aux
toilettes s'il vous plaît donc je suis
sorti à ce moment là je tombe sur
directeur qui s'appelait moschetti qui
était mon directeur à charlemagne parce
que j'étais aussi à charlemagne on a
essayé de me glisser là bas il médite de
l'eau qu'est ce que vous faites là je
suis monsieur j'ai mal aux couilles j'ai
demandé à sortir ça c'est véridique
immédiat seuil et vous ça va passer j'ai
ouvert un petit massage
j'avais 17 ans
c'est normal elles sont pleines il est
parti et puis dès qu'il a tourné la
porte et j'ai dit c'est fini je veux
plus tu peux pas arrêter machin pour
faire quoi et puis je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai dix photographes ouais photographe
donc là à votre père vous dis j'aurais
pu dire n'importe bref je vais soumettre
en maison de correction en pologne
yougoslavie et là vous vous retrouvez
seul dans un appartement à paris
prêté par une danseuse du crazy horse
qui étaient partis effectivement j'étais
un peu lâchés dans la nature mam est un
bon vivant aux etats unis
mon père est moins c'était c'était
la brouille donc je me suis retrouvé
comme ça et puis j'ai habité à droite à
gauche chez des copains etc jusqu'au
jour effectivement cette fille qui est
décroché un contrat de danseuse au crazy
au mexique nous a laissé son appartement
sympa les filles du crazy
donc on était dans la cité va dans la
partie les deux briquets ce qu'on va
mettre dans le frigo voilà qui nous
ramène dans le frigo donc effectivement
on fait des conneries oui bon après vous
êtes un peu défoncé après le bond bien
après bien après un contre 20 et 30
ouais et après bien sûr la principauté
vous avez alors grenache moi c'était 100
g a cepandant ouais c'est pourtant c'est
non et pourtant vous avez du succès au
cinéma c'est ça qui est assez
incompréhensible c'est dans chronique
d'une mort annoncée le film de de rossi
vous aviez eu beaucoup de succès léger
il avait salué votre talent rosie
c'était bien c'était bien d'ailleurs
c'est le premier qu'on a vu c'est le
premier qui est sorti on a été à cannes
pour ça et effectivement ouais j'avais
bien démarré
mais ça a coïncidé avec justement le
moment où où je me suis j'ai commencé à
déconner et derrière ça
j'avais plus envie de travailler je
faisais des conneries je me défoncer je
faisais voilà et puis deux ans après on
m'a dit mon agent à l'époque m'a dit tu
sais il faut que tu tournes parce qu'on
va t'oublier et j'ai fait la femme
fardée et la faisait tellement beau et
que c'était pas terrible et là j'étais
tellement bourré que ce n'était pas
terrible et à ce moment là je me suis
fait je me suis fait casser c'est normal
ouais vous êtes pris conscience quand et
comment qui fait d'arrêter la dope
j'ai pris conscience vingt neuf jours où
je
je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais devenu un
esclave est que la
doc m'avait pris ma liberté et ma
dignité alors aujourd'hui ça va bien
vous êtes avec sophie voilà une petite
fille qui s'appelle semaine nous vous ai
fait une psychothérapie j'ai fait une
psychothérapie analytique oui pendant
que dans en prenant deux ans puis
ensuite par moments j'ai retourné le
voir pour parler pour la série glee
ouais mais après ça devient commun ça
devient amie ça devient un membre de la
famille
je peux avoir envie de lui parler je
l'appelle je lui parle c'est bien parce
que c'est tout un c'est gratos m'attend
c'est un pote s'est jamais gratos
après c'est une si une gymnastique quand
on arrive quand on a du mal à parler à
ses amis ou même se parler à soi on
s'assoit puis c'est tout un
un truc qui en route et puis paf c'est
ça aide quoi si c'était à refaire je le
referais tout pareil tous pareils même
l'ado tout j'ai marché les deux longs
pourri à ce groupe comme ça un peu du
côté gangster un peu parce que quand on
lit les quand on lit la biographie de
votre père même s'il n'est pas autorisée
ce qui est sorti et est pas complètement
faux il aimait bien jouer des révolvers
tout ça ça vient de doute ça par rapport
aux belmondo qui sont très rangée c'est
vrai qu'en plus
on demande aux
usages et des gens qui se droguent pas
alors répond non ça vient d'où
lui il aime les armes il les a toujours
aimé jeu c'est comme ça je dis moi
j'aime j'aime plus tellement ça en fait
je crois que - et j'ai été un petit peu
et c'est normal j'ai grandi avec le
culte d'un père était qui était acteur
mais qui était surtout
reste la star la plus grande star
française
pendant 25 ans et puis qui était
toujours un flic ou un voyou un flic ou
voyou il a toujours un instant les mains
ou un zorro moi j 3 euros mais bon donc
mais si cette fois que la mutation de
l'image du père voilà c'est normal oui
c'est bien le mimétisme toujours qui
fait que quand on vous voit dans ce film
on regrette que finalement après la
chronique d'une mort annoncée vous ayez
pas continuer merci et alors ce qui est
très bien c'est que vous êtes souvent
dans l'autodérision et c'est vrai qu'en
plus j'ai beaucoup de bon sens quelque
chose de nouveau chez vous c'est que
vous avez de la distance par rapport à
votre personnage à ce que vous êtes quoi
et ça c'est nouveau c'est vrai
j'ai de la distance parce que enfin si
vous d'abord je me suis jamais pris au
sérieux mais sinon nous non plus on t'a
jamais eu aussi
je me suis jamais pris au sérieux mais
j'avais une distance plutôt une distance
par rapport
en fait j'en avais ras le bol voilà j'en
avais ras le bol que les gens se fassent
une fausse idée parce que c'est vrai que
ça fait 15 ans john tu es quand j je me
tais serre que bon on me demande
toujours fait une interwiew fautif est
là et je le fais pas parce que parce que
j'avais pas envie et parce que bon pour
des raisons multiples et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je me suis dit mais quand
je rencontre quelqu'un me dit mais ramé
c'est drôle je pensais pas que c'était
comme ça je pensais que c'était un coup
enfin ils ne disent pas mais il le pense
ou peut-être prétentieux ou tt ce site
est fait cela 1 et
en fait c'est pas ça et un moment j'ai
dit au four
j'ai beaucoup changé aussi c'est vrai
qu'à une époque
il ya une époque où fermiers comme une
huître ouais mais c'est venu c'est venu
de tout temps une accumulation de choses
c'est venu de la femme fardée où je me
suis fait massacrer après c'est vrai que
je les prie je les prie je les prie en
pleine gueule et que j'ai pas j'arrive
enfin j'avais 20 ans je veux dire à ce
moment là on n'est pas capable de
prendre du recul gt gt en plein dedans
et et et j'ai donné le bâton pour se
faire battre et puis si on met on m'a
allumé c'est moi qui ai déconné c'est ma
tribu c'est moi qui ai fait des
conneries c'est moi qui me suis défoncé
c'est de ma faute mais si tu veux ma
première réaction est là et et le rejet
ah ouais vous moi je suis nas dans ce
film et oum allez vous faire [ __ ] ça
je suis allé
en écharde où la cgt un peu dans tous
les sens il ya hervé bourges ce soir au
quai d'ailleurs hervé j'ai demandé de
rentrer maintenant
aller bien servi
il est sur le coup
bientôt va aller regarder
modérer vos propos d'accord on est
content de voir comme ça vous allez en
milieu ouvert mieux dans votre peau plus
à l'aise c'est vrai ce qui arrive c'est
que là les excès que vous avez fait vous
ont pas marqué
bien alors anthony delon
vous avez eu des eaux vous avez eu des
bas on va faire l'interview à penda
le sait tout le monde le sait le couche
pas pendant le finger
bien alors anthony delon ce que vous
préférez en vous mes mains
ce que vous détestez en vous mon père
n'aurait
l'anxiété ouais ce que vous préférez au
cinéma
rêvé que vous haïssez au cinéma
la complaisance
le film de vous que vous préférez jeu de
con je viens de vous vous détestez
y en a beaucoup
lépine en choeur
le plus grand moment de votre vie
la naissance de ma fille vous
responsabilités de père de famille
maintenant c'est vrai que quand on a on
a un enfant on est on nous prend enfin
quelque part on se remet attaché on est
attaché à cet enfant bien sûr mais on
est attaché à certaines choses on n'a
plus toutes les libertés cirque de
demain je peux pas prendre ma valise et
partirez
disparaître
c'est bien vous trouvez ça bien c'est
bien mais c'est dur aussi ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui a besoin de vous
maintenant ouais ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie il ya plein de choses
qui me plaisent
jamais être entre amis j'aime j'aime
aller au cinéma j'aime rire beaucoup
arrête tu vas trop loin déjà c'est
pas qu'elle rende ma fille dans mes bras
j'ai
enfin j'aime tous les joueurs de la vie
ce qui fait le plus chiant réveiller
les cons votre plus gros coup de fric le
crédit lyonnais raconte
j'ai jamais eu un gros coup de fric
votre plus grosse perte
ma plus grosse perte et ben ça sera
peut-être jeu de cons parce que je de
congés jouer dedans mais j'ai produit
aussi ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans
la vie
les trucs qu'on les gags le le zloty
enfin le gepan ont de si reagan qui
descend de l'avion et qui se vautre qui
attrape son garde du corps qui tombent
avec lui enfin ce genre de truc quoi ça
me fait rire et le moi rire
les drames
tout ce que je vois à la télé
leur plus belle histoire d'amour abaissé
celle là nancy reagan
sans déconner est appelée chaude en ciel
pas que nancy reagan
me précédemment la plus minable
bernadette
les traits souhaite pas
je sais plus j'en ai plein il y en a eu
plein enfin tu sais le truc 5h du mat tu
rentres débours et il rate vous dit
si vous êtes de plus sexy en vous
elle a dit les yeux le derrière dit les
couilles
la faillite après je sais on a failli
échapper 600 intervenants plaisanciers
ses passes cash si pascal sellem s'était
pas cassé une côte et de moi un sexy
la leaf est dit quelque chose
et avaient gagné 17 ans le public ils
font les couilles vraiment le monde a
changé 1 je sais pas moi les genoux
ouais voilà les genoux ouais ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe le plaisir de
l'autre c'est bien le dire ça à la télé
mais le plaisir de l'autre c'est aussi
mon plaisir c'est que ta femme va voir
l'émission on n'est pas couché ce que
vous détestez dans le sexe ce que je
déteste cesser la pédophilie par exemple
sujet l'agent dire un truc la semaine
dernière jean hugues anglade lui
demander si tu es homo il m'a dit qu'il
avait été violé par un pédophile à l'âge
de 13 ans et demi j'oserais dire ce soir
que kim ans j'étais choquée j'ai pas
corrigé évidemment pas être homosexuel
sans être pédophile d'azur et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus